and I swear you my wife and I we're
watching we have an l-shaped couch so we
weren't even right next to each other
that could have been some telepathic
communication we just both went oh
that's good and we felt very ashamed of
ourselves only all right so some of the
latest Co vid news right now
ouchy ouchy however you pronounce it I
don't really care
predicted up to one hundred and two
hundred thousand deaths in the United
States and so Trump has changed the
guidelines now where we're going to be
extending social distancing we're not
until Easter which would be a beautiful
time it'd be such a beautiful wooden tit
be a beautiful timeline whatever
mitigates the disease but I do
understand I had to understand him
wanting to be hopeful in Kathy he's a
guy he likes a narrative yeah I mean you
know and if we had it going until Easter
when he rose and we destroyed the
coronavirus they rolled over the big
boulder to the tube okay and they said
he's no fairy should put you're headed
by side and we should know that unless
you watch them kuroda your dad by Savior
Corinthians two let's go to a clip
actually of Donald Trump for those who
have missed it this is the news this
morning on him changing or extending the
guidelines therefore we will be
extending our guidelines to April 30th
to slow the spread on Tuesday we'll be
finalizing these plans and providing a
summary of our findings supporting data
and strategy to the American people okay
so I want to be clear about something
here everyone now saying okay we're
definitely going to have the number is
100 and 200,000 in the United States you
think that's accurate
I think it's as accurate as they can
figure out right now right probably
overblown I think it's as actor as I can
figure out right now considering that
the original study that they used for
the modeling predicted 2.5 million in
the United States and then in the UK was
half a million I believe right and then
they down read it to 20,000 or Cuba or
much less I'm no math guy but that's
different that it is
significant it's like listen 99% of
Americans will die before the age of 60
this year
what really or 1% we don't know some put
it pays to get some hand sanitizer
I appreciate the you know the verbal
accuracy though right if you're like
it's between zero and 10 billion people
will die
right this year yeah I mean you can't
it's harder to get more accurate unless
you said zero to 11 billion will just
make us in space the crazy thing is I
and I've been watching CNN and preparing
for this and you let me know we'll be
chatting with you over there plays TV
it's easy to get scared it's easy to get
scared when you watch Tina Chris Coleman
was on CNN going and Donald Trump this
is killing Americans you have blood on
your hands you don't care about American
lives and they go we passed every other
country as far as infections you hold on
the rate that matters is per capita that
is relevant because you can't compare us
to a country that has a tenth of the
population depending on which country
I'm talking about yo and if you look at
the per capita death in the United it's
very very low it's like five or six
compared to China Italy it's not even
close it's not even close so it's easy
to get scared of course I understand it
we should all do what we can to avoid
the virus but this idea right now that
you some here somehow don't care about
the deaths of Americans if you say hey
completely crippling the economy which
will lead to mass unemployment
starvation and by the way their
insurance and potentially dying from
other more deadly diseases yes you do
have to weigh the pros and cons of all
these issues yeah
there's no considering it in what I
actually find interesting is that you'll
see people talking about the lives and
well you know we need to do everything
possible no questions asked we have to
be able to save as many lives as we can
and yet in the same statement they're
like why can't we get back to work right
and it was like hold on oh look you
understand that those two things are
different and you know you're gonna have
to make some hard decisions and that the
government is wrangling with those
things whether whether you're a Democrat
or Republican right I mean no matter
what side you're on both of those
parties are trying to figure out they
have different ideas about what that
solution looks like right and certainly
we believe there's one of the halves is
better than the other but it seems to me
we're going I said this before we're
going about the wrong way but what
arbitrary creating this list of what are
the essential business how about we do
this how about weak warned in Italy I
have an Italy 90
90% of people who died 99% this from the
New York Post had pre-existing
conditions the guy who created the
Imperial study or or was a associate
with the Imperial study Neela is it Neil
Ferguson yeah he admitted that
two-thirds of the people who died from
coronavirus would have died within that
year anyway now I'm not saying let's
accelerate it or decrease the surplus
population as we know what that is
different lead to it if 99% of people
have a pre-existing condition that is
relevant people should know that because
if they don't have a pre-existing
condition and they get the sniffles not
only should you not go panic by toilet
paper but you should not be going to the
emergency room and cluttering up space
that could be used for not only people
with coronavirus by the way there are
still people out there with emphysema
and stage 4 cancer and other serious
illnesses like they need care too and a
lot of hospitals have shut that down I
think it was in Brooklyn
I don't have this in front of me there
was another hospital that opens out all
that today just serve you know on
coronavirus patients because they said
they're being vastly under eka guised by
doctors one of the big solutions it one
of the big solutions has worked in other
countries and that certainly could be an
option here is you identify the fillable
who are well I mean I think they're
killing themselves not all of them just
the ones who tip 2/4 yeah just those
guys if it's if it's less than 2/4 yeah
I mean I've got no sympathy
the Sanders is not kill the Sanders is
only if they tip 2/4 only if you took
them on that do-not-resuscitate list all
right anyone out there in the service
industry you know those people that do
pew orders I know you have a list I know
it's in red lipstick said I would be in
red lipstick are you talking to your
mistress right now is this your way of
communicating don't sext on my show mr.
movie never saw Billy Madison Steve
Buscemi's riding the list and red
lipstick okay you know I mean I think
that you're about to make yeah do you
don't watch movies I know the point but
the point is the point is you've got
people who are especially susceptible
and we know without question nobody
disagrees that more certain people in
certain age groups or pre-existing
conditions are more at risk so what we
need to do is very strongly isolating
those individuals because amongst you
even amongst the family right I said
this a long time ago and the weeks ago
isolate old people and the vulnerable we
should be this is just an
piñon okay and you can get really upset
with me it's not that I don't care about
grandpa and grandma this is what we have
in the office we have young healthy
people who have no symptoms who are we
probably had it in this office in
January honestly possible yeah because
it was it came in much earlier than news
and then the party older employees who
are over the age of 55 are working from
right we've taken those precautions I
don't know why why don't we create a
list of non-essential businesses that
should be closed why don't we create a
list of people who should be quarantined
at this point rather than say everything
shut down everybody panic everybody stay
in the house when the fact is it's
affecting a very small percentage of
people here's something else that nobody
tells you the corona but not this corona
virus is a novel coronavirus but if you
have Lysol if you have matte cleaner and
it's like that or you clean an
industrial kitchen you have a bottle and
it says kills corona virus that's been
around for a while corona virus some
form of it not this form is typically it
typically makes up somewhere I think it
was seven to fourteen percent of all
influenza cases and right now they're
not necessarily taking that into account
so at this point at this point if you
were to lump in all corona virus deaths
okay
Alcorn a virus deaths with the flu
deaths this year in other words if we
had not recognized it and we would just
attribute all this to flu deaths it
still wouldn't be an abnormally high
season for flu deaths so let's keep that
in context it matters we need to fight
this thank god private industry is
stepping up and helping us but I am NOT
this is I'm not gonna be shamed into
panicking they're using a lot of the
same tactics that they used with climate
change right now with people if they go
hey listen I don't think that we should
shut down everything indefinitely yeah
we might look into some states opening
up more industry specifically to people
who aren't all that vulnerable in you or
absolutely excoriate you're turned into
this like you're a pedophile it rights
for so long what's crazy about this is
it's already happening right now we've
already made the decision to choose
certain businesses as writers because
people go oh if you're within six feet
of somebody you're an [ __ ] and it's
like well you know I probably should
hold my toddler I don't know I don't
know hard to be a good parent right
Stacy well but that's okay well well
what about at the grocery store well as
long as you stay six feet away but if
you grab the same box of Cheerios yeah
yes I mean like we already know
that we there are ways to reduce the
risks and requires being specific yeah
and right now I get it like people
people are panicking governments are
panicking and they're just saying you
shut it all down
you shouldn't shut it all down that the
Italian Prime Minister you know the
cowboyhat do a funny accent during every
press briefing right and I'm telling you
morale will go through the roof I don't
know if it'll go through the roof with
the funny voices yeah with the funny
picture hey you know what that's the
thing I think if they could just deliver
it with a funny voice like 5% of you
probably going to die slow painful did
they like to Pompey I like to write this
skateboard here is my clown and just
comes in and comes dead
I forgot by the way we should have done
this is morning news Renda the first
thing that we do is morning news roundup
we already did a story but here we go
morning news roundup
[Music]
I don't know what that is yes so much
slurping yeah we got that music from
First Baptist Church thanks for taking
part at First Baptist Church here's a
little bit of what's going on in our
neck of the woods
I think that's Potanin he's down to
three Chin's Al Roker yeah from six he's
dropped down from I don't know what six
I mean you'd say at five and a half I'm
gonna give him that knife because he and
generally needs it
do we have actually before we move on we
have more we do have a traffic report
because the morning show a new show for
you guys hit the notification bell by
the way if you're subscribed on YouTube
use a promo code quarantine hashtag mug
club quarantine we'll be reading some of
your comments tweets a little bit later
on but only for mug club members
everyone else you get to watch it for
free but you don't get to talk with that
fasion bill that's a privilege that
arises it's effectively a goods or
service yes and you need to provide some
kind of a commodity preferably pictures
some with you wearing very little
clothing that's for bill
that's right agent Oh for the mistress
all right but we have the traffic report
right with a Thomas Finnegan
[Music]
well that is grating Thomas Finnegan do
we have Thomas Finnegan our traffic
reporter on the line Thomas are you
there good morning Steven how are you
I'm fine what can we expect this morning
as people are taking part in their
morning commute well we're seeing some
traffic from the bathroom to the kitchen
and you want to watch out you got a
straight socked in there so you want to
hug less okay thank you very mean the
wall correct okay well it's a problem
because I have I have a centerpiece
there in that wall with a with a vase so
you'll need to move that this is why I
appreciate it okay is there anything
else we should know Thomas that's about
it there was a pileup of but that's been
cleared away so free free lanes for all
okay thank you much this has been the
traffic update with Thomas Finnegan
[Music]
okay so my next story topic can I tell
you I like finnegans mustache I do
it's well you know what it's from a
bygone era yeah it really excited to
hang on to it you know it is from still
from a bygone era but remains that
before I move on to the corona virus
testing kids because this is good news
no this the the pajama pee hole space
what is it with pajamas were they they
put a button on the crotch but it's way
high up and there's this oh look look
let me show you this this my wife had to
add okay my wife had to add this button
this button wasn't here okay I'm wearing
underwear but if I was not wearing
underwear look at this look at this look
at this why yeah why would you do this
look at the space from here to here
compared to the space from here easy
look at that okay quarterback Garrett
Shaw show him yours too
weird to put a safety pin on
quarterblack it Shawn jump it's the same
problem those are from JCPenney
this is from me yeah look at it put your
finger through poor-quality take your
take your take your pin out put the
finger through this is a problem I have
I've had three times where my schlong
almost fell out G of yours audio way
yeah it's too much they decided with we
know with jeans if you have button flies
the buttons go all the way down the
middle of the page right with pajamas
they decide we're gonna close up a gap
of four millimeters at the top of the
flap yeah and bottom about a foot and a
half I'm gonna make a sign my brother
angry mom dated a girl named Holly in
high school I was wearing Joe Boxer
pajama pants and I was turning I was
looking watching TV like this you know
in the book reading post I turned around
because she was on the couch and I
turned around and when I turned around I
felt a breeze oh that's a telltale yeah
Wow and I was a late bloomer so I was
embarrassed because it's very small and
then the other this this Christmas this
Christmas my mother-in-law gets me a
thermal Union suit okay
because we're in Reno Nevada and we're
skiing and stuff like that I mean they
ski and the night and I just drink in
the in the Cabana button-down plaid I
think at night you know what I'm gonna
put this on and go on down with my
mother show her that I enjoy the jammy
she got me for Christmas and as I walk
there's a there's a
sliding door mirror in the bedroom I
take one step one step and it was enough
inertia to and my my pecker fell right
out and I was going I just avoid by the
skin my screwed right there I just
avoided my mother-in-law seeing all of
it oh wow yes that's terrifying let me
know in the chat or tweet me a discredit
if you as a man if you've seen as every
brand of underwear not underwear pajamas
under weight yeah underwear they put on
two buttons and you'd think it would be
the same yeah underwear you got you
already figured it out over here right
put it on the pajamas yeah I'm at the
point that my wife asked me if I bought
my pajamas at a sex shop because she
thought they were crotchless men's
pajamas yeah they're not arrington this
is just how they do it okay
let's move on to talk about right now
the FDA this is big news in in Corona
everything is pretty much gone right now
but a lot of people may miss why this is
important the private sector is stepped
up the FDA just approved a new
five-minute Corona test that could be a
whole new ball game I think we have a
clip to talk about it on Friday the FDA
authorized a new test developed by
Abbott Labs that delivers lightning-fast
results in as little as five minutes
that's a whole new ballgame whole new
ball game ball games no ball games
totally illegal right now president it
could be stickball if they're playing
out in the neighborhood and it's six
feet apart six feet apart
what is stickball is it just baseball
with a stick word smartness I believe so
it's baseball for poor people is that
what it kind of like a tea ball is
baseball for homos or children yeah I'm
gay but we repeat ourselves young all
these children we talk about this with
dr. Choi last week right where he said
oh it's getting getting better we have
we had five tests now we have 3035 and
that was from quest labs and I know that
because I do bloodwork regularly from
like kind of pre-existing health
conditions where I go there about every
two months so I know quest labs they're
very quick they turnaround things
quickly you were saying that they had
created a lab test for Corona and now
they were getting more tests and that's
a private that's a private less and this
one is coming from I believe Abbott
Laboratories keep in mind that only a
few weeks ago the fastest test was
several hours
now we're talking about 5-minute tests
that don't require them then go up into
your sinus like that film artificial
intelligence we'd love to see the
cutaway of like what it looks like when
they put the thing down yes I just oh
man they're actually touching your brain
oh but it's pretty close pretty close I
don't think they have to do that anymore
though know what they just saw right in
your skull think about this for a second
yeah one of those when we talk about how
we need socialized health care in this
example we've socialized health care
well well um the CDC they were the only
ones who were cleared by the FDA to
create these tests right they weren't
ready in time and it took hours or
significant turnaround time they had to
swab your brain and it didn't work the
second we approve any from private
businesses you can do it in five minutes
at home and you don't have to scratch
your medulla oblongata
I do find ya it's interesting how many
people are like I can't believe we're
gonna let these private companies make
money off this okay so you're against
jobs oh no I mean no I'm not against
jobs just people making money just at
their jobs yeah let me simplify my point
of view whoever develops the cure for
coronavirus should be a trillionaire oh
yeah step aside Jeff Bezos I don't care
what you do I don't care if you do next
hour shipping you should the guide you
guys just walk through go outside yet
Korona swab yeah i do the corona swab
and you make crappy movies because you
have all this money but for some reason
you desperately want to be a part of
hollywood no understands it's about Jeff
Bezos but it really is really what are
ya why is he at the Oscars yeah that's a
bizarre thing don't do we not think that
the guy who creates a cure of this lab
the five-minute test deserve more than
some loose pocket change yes
and can you name me one example the
country one wimple during this pandemic
people out there one example where the
government has been more efficient than
private industry stepping in Oh Eddie
send it to rickets now I mean only in
the things that they don't let anyone
else do like nukes right that's true oh
let's talk about the corona virus yeah
but I mean that's what I mean maybe
that's a cure every well I mean it is
but not the kind of cure we want like a
famous depends but it's not nuking
people look it maybe just call me Asian
you guys have a sore spot about that one
young radiation it's not the folks at
the post office that you want developing
this cure yeah you want you want like
some folks who are have some innovation
have some ambition and actually want to
use the stuff that they have the skills
that they have right and yeah make tons
of money and also I would I would trust
to cure more sort of FedEx like if we
decided to entrust the cure to a carrier
service yeah right go FedEx yeah right I
would believe that by the way speaking
of which we have some sponsors here
this morning's ition of good morning Mon
club's brought to you by toast TARDIS
putting butter on a regular piece of
normal colored bread sick of stopping up
your plate of eggs with a second plate
of eggs now you don't have to with toast
toast is similar to bread but worlds
apart because toast is a result of your
bread after it's been heated in a device
afterward it emerges slightly darker you
can use the toast as a side
accompaniment to a meal on its own go to
toast calm and enter the promo code
toast for 70% off your first order
that's toast dot-com promo code tio ast
that's the order the next 10 minutes
will include a discount on the lot of
credit proprietary Browning breadbox so
that you can actually make your own
toast at home you can make home yeah
with a lighter with Crowder I love it
it's a great accompany to the mug Club
use the promo code yeah tio ast sip you
know what I'm feeling generous just like
we're doing the mug club yeah month
right ninety nine percent off whoa nine
thousand off the toast from CEO ast is
lightly browning bread box or the
Browning bro be clear we don't have
utility patents but we do have
provisional patents pending and then we
were immediately told if they're not
pending they're no longer so so but we
can sell them to you a lot of stock to
get rid of by the way something to keep
in mind the CDC the or it depends the FT
idea who you want to look at with this
they never replenish the stock pile of
masks after Ebola and I know this is
insane that they didn't have the
foresight to go hey we just had a giant
giant thing going on and we used all the
mass yeah thing isn't as descriptive we
had a giant thing going I'm gonna say it
anyways and they didn't think to
replenish the mask well they're gonna
blame Donald this came out they tried to
blame Donald Trump because he was
sending over equipment to China
right there so always blaming that the
stock wasn't replenished he sent stuff
to China keep in mind just a few weeks
ago they were blaming him for not
sending enough supplies to China so they
were blaming enough supplies so he felt
like he had to send some supplies right
and of course then he realized oh wait
there's net we don't have enough so they
never replenish the supplies
that's like me way to say wait wait and
it's not a sponsor I don't think cuz
they're sold out but prepare with
Crowder we had those sort of yeah but
you're not calling me a conspiracy
theorist now I thought my wife and I ate
all the oatmeal because it was so tasty
better than oatmeal and then we realized
when this went down what do we have as
far as he whole I don't have the
broccoli cheddar soup starve
[Music]
we just we didn't we didn't replenish
I've gotta start eating twice it's
remarkable to me that he honestly has
been blamed for sending stuff to China I
understand I don't think you should have
sent equipment to China no you should
have yeah but keep in mind at that point
we didn't know how bad it was gonna be
because they told us that it wasn't
going to be sending masks to China that
were made in China no he's the one we
can probably this up I think Donald
Trump is the one president or one leader
maybe there's another one like I don't
know like in Botswana I have no idea but
of the major countries who's refused
testing kits I think and masochists or
mass I think in China
I definitely mash and they don't work
yeah what doesn't work the masks yeah so
the masses that come from China people
been using them and they're like yeah
you know those masks that you thought
they were helpful I don't do that all
Chinese immediately higher failure rate
and Donald Trump said no masks from
China there's a video floating around of
this guy in a Chinese manufacturer and
he's rubbing the masks on his shoes have
you seen that I wonder doing that China
does Corona shoes he's doing this before
he ships out the masks they're all yeah
they're in the manufacturing place that
just seems spiteful hope you enjoy I
don't well we this is a thing
he might be [ __ ] because in
friendship club true story my wife my
wife was this girl was really jealous of
my wife's relationship with her aunt and
what they did was they would go to
sometimes Disney World of people this
was this thing was like special needs a
group and so they would go to Disney
World every year and she this other
mentally handicapped already a
special-needs mentally handicapped met
and disabled right
whatever the term is that doesn't offend
you most yeah what a fee she was upset
that my wife had a close relationship
with her aunt who was leading this
function to Disney World and my wife
came home I'm wearing shoes I don't like
but my wife came home to her hotel room
and Disney World that night and out of
spite the special-needs girl had she was
snow angel in my wife's bed and rubbing
her shoes on the pillow because she was
jealous of her aunt what is the kind of
behavior it's the kind of behavior that
you accept because she's mentally
handicapped or a member of an tufa right
or right spur bus that's my point is
this this prejudice of soft expectations
right it's wonderful for mentally
disabled people not so much just because
someone's a minority right like I
wouldn't allow you to rub your feet on
my pillow it's okay you don't have to
let me well it's already happened
Chinese foot binding you know it's
wrapping it in a pillowcase and tying it
up with a nice bow what else do we have
here CDC was the only place to prove to
kids I don't know get the JFK oh that's
right here's something else that I saw
this morning in news of the morning this
is important
the FDA they're still preventing
obviously some private companies from
conducting as many tests as they could
some companies could supply a hundred
and sixty thousand a day they're only
allowing a hundred thousand and Donald
Trump remember this when he'd had that
that what he called summit press
conference whatever he's doing the
briefings really coldness and he said
maybe we could find a way to reuse masks
where maybe you could spray them with
some kind of elaborate sand and then
they said there's no way to sterilize
these masks the FDA has now amended its
initial approval granted early Sunday
now allowing Patel to sterilize the n95
surgical masks without a daily limit
they can be sterilized reused 20 times
thanks to the FDA's loosening rules you
know if just capitalism is allowed to go
unchecked we're gonna beat this
coronavirus and then where will CNN be
yeah
they also gentlemen we have to preserve
the job of second-rate reporters we do
by allowing this virus to continue let's
see spin wise yes I am I'm saying that
because that's not that's a lie let's go
to live CNN right now we're
we're looking at the USS comfort this is
the hospital ship okay that's another
interesting one by the way was it the
princess the cruise oh yeah
the princess cruise I think it 3000
pieces again this is a little more free
flow you guys let me know we'll chat
with you soon
the princess cruise had 3,000 people 700
700 of them got infected
the death rate when you work on the ship
it was 1% and then when you account for
people who were below the age of 70 it
was much much lower like the death rate
for people who were below 70 didn't have
any kind of pre-existing conditions yo
you were talking about a miniscule
amount it's the closest thing that we
have to a sample study of knowing who's
infected and knowing as much as we could
possibly know about their health effects
no one's talking about it it's
remarkable today yeah well because all
so you're saying that all of those
people on the boat were tested 700 of
them seven or something you hosted
positive right and then there's a 1%
death rate so yeah that that is
basically a lab experiment all just yeah
it's because they're all right they're
all floating around I mean they're not
willing guinea pigs don't get me wrong
like they weren't thrilled abort victim
of circumstance which shows to get on
that boat guinea pigs are not willing
guinea pigs usually there's no that's
true yeah but we don't really care every
single guinea pig signs a waiver oh I
didn't know that is the hallmarks it's
really just claw marks and on the other
side of the door once you lock them in
and we take that as a form of yeah it's
a door we're gonna consent also by the
way consent big issue for guinea pigs in
the in the fraternity sorority houses
lots of guinea pig rape yeah it's a real
problems that is that no that was just
guinea pigs
well that's what you would think in
other words we just say guinea pig gonna
guinea pig but we didn't take into
account that many female guinea pigs I
mean have been oppressed for a long time
like they're not they're not big fans of
it well we should care about like when
we say they copulate like rabbits we
just think that rabbits we assume that
both parties involved right wanted to
copulate yeah so we assumed this just er
they breed or sometimes it's like
copulate like Chinese you know there's
something that breeds a lot a lot a lot
of people 3 billion Chinese 18 billion
rabbits turns out it's actually just
rape so this colloquialism is really
minimizing which colloquialism the they
copulate like rabbits oh why it's not
return my guinea pigs I'm catching up
well I'm saying rabbits are similar
right right I know that they're
different and and the Chinese we've all
read the Richard Gere story my point
here is that we're both willing
participants and we are now finding out
that's not the case yeah you know that
is Richard Gere was not the consenting
party no that's the that's the tragedy
of that story is Richard Gere was the
one who was saying no oh really yeah
poor guy
he just can't catch a break no no all
the stuff is straight-to-dvd than that
crappy dog film everywhere oh gee what
was it called cool the dog still waiting
it rains day for Rogie
yeah is a pierogi the Polish dog pierogi
we're gonna get to a little bit trumps
president Trump slow response that's
what he's been accused of here recently
but before we do that actually I want to
keep things in context and will we get
into some of your chat here in a little
bit or send in your pictures in the
morning with your mug at twitter.com
slash s Crowder keep it in context
because in Canada things are very
different as a matter of fact right now
there are people who are being arrested
and fined thousands of dollars right for
going outside and violating the sort of
lockdown orders which to me is really
scary just as scary or scarier than the
coronavirus is the complete absolve Minh
of rights that have been long-standing
because we're afraid of the microbe not
saying it's not serious
but that is equally we need to weigh
this so actually our favorite Greek
Canadian who helps work with the show
behind the scenes but he's going to be a
Canadian correspondent right now to
pride a little context and hopefully
make you feel better about your day
let's go to stories with pen Telus
I know it's crazy but I wanted to give
you guys a story to let you know that it
could be worse
like be positive everything's gonna have
a buddy a couple years ago he went to
jail and we had a little party that we
were all out at a little while after you
got out of jail it wasn't for him the
party but he was there and I started
making a lot of jokes about prison cuz I
like to screw with people and then he
stormed out of the room and one of my
friends I was there told me yeah don't
make a lot of jokes he went kind of
crazy in jail cuz apparently he he
watches too many movies and when he got
into jail cuz he didn't know anybody in
there he went and attacked someone that
was like a known tough guy and he ended
up getting the [ __ ] kicked out of him
and then raped repeatedly by like a lot
of people and I was like a daily
occurrence where he get beat up and
raped so it could always be worse as I'm
saying don't don't do the crime if
you're not willing to go to jail and get
raped and if you don't want to go
through that or if you're not willing to
rape maybe that would have helped point
is this virus thing could be worse it's
always nice to put things in context by
the way half-asian bill had to go
urinate oh my goodness he is a bulldog
but he has a very small bladder Bulldogs
have pretty small bladder that's right
because of the horrendous inbreeding
yeah exactly and a designer breed you
gotta sit him in there yo gravity chair
and put a CPAP on them while they sleep
give some massage their lower intestines
so that they can they can make it's
almost like they should so they can make
nicest the Bulldogs they really
shouldn't exist have to deliver them all
by c-section is this a premium nature
this is yeah make is that make I've
never seen this before well I mean it
makes sense just make I think it might
be sign language I like I don't know I
like something my mom used to use it
every now and then it's disgusting let's
go to CNN real quick and see what they
have right now and see we've gotten
wrong so far it's all about how can we
help these folks try to get back on
their feet try to you know get through
weather this storm this is not just an
issue in San Diego but this is an issue
obviously all across the country so I've
really tried to set the tone here in San
Diego it's not to be feared Democrat
looking it's bringing this city together
putting policies people and help close
the damn door bill come on
San Diego mayor yeah good luck together
and the right let's go fred armisen care
by the way you mind they have total they
have total cases and deaths on their
than the united states total cases and
deaths this is something when you tuned
in to CNN in one of these mornings we'll
be doing just watching CNN fact-checking
during the break almost like an
ombudsman those numbers are
significantly lower than deaths from the
flu right significantly lower and so it
does matter when the models that were
used predicted twenty to fifty times
higher deaths especially when you
consider the fact that these deaths are
significantly lower than our registering
right now if you take into account
people who are over the age of eighty or
if you take into account people at
serious pre-existing conditions who are
going to die within that year anyway not
saying we shouldn't take care of them
because this isn't a socialized health
care country that's very common in
Canada or in Italy where they just don't
help you no matter what the fact the do
not resuscitate order is a controversy
in the United States tells you the
different standard of care that we have
in here but they just want to toss that
up to scare everybody and show that the
United States has handled us the most
poorly actually look at countries with
socialized health care system and you
look at the per capita deaths we have
handled it incredibly well the biggest
hiccups the biggest log jams that we
have had have been the FDA and the CDC
and it's still happening it's still
happening with cures it's still
happening with vaccinations it's still
happening with tests think about
everything that we've had problems with
we need more masks in private industry
is stepping up to fix it we need more
ventilators private industry is stepping
up to fix it we need more tests private
labs are stepping up to fix it we more
space private hospitals private private
caretakers now that apparently that
concierge doctors now are reaching out
and helping people I wouldn't be
surprised if at some point they start
creating like you know if they have like
at home care centers yeah well there's a
lot of doctors now just really not just
a random guy two trucks that yeah well
speaking of the media trying to scare
people I mean it was trending on Twitter
this morning CBS News was using shots
from an Italian hospital and when they
were talking about New York right and so
it's it really is a big part of this
narrative and so it if you show if you
show these pictures of like 30 beds full
of people it's it
is gonna make a difference where you say
the party said it was turning onto us
you know what would horrify ya Americans
right outside of the coronavirus shots
of Italian hospitals yes it is Jared
yeah period yeah people don't realize
when I went to it was Blodgett Hospital
when I moved to Michigan it was in Grand
Rapids and I was this is when I so there
were two times that I can remember going
to the hospital yeah one time was when I
tore my knee completely tore it and I
had to get knee surgery and the other
time was turned out I had a small like a
stomach flu and I got kneed in the balls
and so what happened was I went to this
because I was like oh my stomach's
really bad and my balls were hurting and
so that seemed like something concerning
what I've forgotten about was this kid
who I was teaching you to like a little
kid need me in the balls but it was like
three days later delayed reaction so I
went to the hospital they were like
drink some kefir ice your balls that was
the fix that was the first time I went
to an American Hospital and my wife took
me in yeah these are this is like a
hotel I've never seen anything like this
and I know not all hospitals are great
here and not all hospitals are terrible
but if you were to take the best
hospitals in Montreal when I lived there
yeah it wasn't even close to this
hospital which wasn't considered
necessarily top tier was an average
Hospital the best Hospital in Canada
would be a horror show to most Americans
let alone Americans who mostly going to
like 24-hour emergency clinics now it's
like going into a Hyatt it's like going
into a Spring Hill Suites so if you were
to show any Americans just Italian
Hospital right oh my god what a horror
show that was before why we should do it
before we should just get a bunch of
photos from before and be like is this
the hospital today
yeah I mean it's just a very it's a very
different standard and in other
countries where you have to you know the
commoditize health care you just you
can't afford the kind of things that we
have here and part of the question is
you're never asking our is Italy gonna
come up with some cure is right where's
this animal I mean all eyes are going to
the US right okay who's gonna fix this
us us I I don't understand how the US is
criticized for being number one right
but then is the sheer fact of being
number one is a point to be critical and
then because you didn't do enough
because you were number one you're
critical as well intervene no no no its
own intervene yeah like intervene but
like just give us money but then leave
it John
but pay three times the average amount
of everyone else pays into NATO you
might we actually of an international
agreement we're all supposed to pay 2%
you're paying 3.6 and most countries are
paying point nine percent how about this
when we pay for our own stimulus bills
which I have a problem with that too by
the way I have a problem with the
stimulus bill because I think there is a
reason for small businesses right we
need to support businesses so that
people don't lose their jobs yeah we
delineate between those people who had
to shut down their restaurants who had
to shut down their place of business
because the government said you are no
longer business everyone else don't
don't patronize their business we need
to delineate between that and the
airlines who are going to be requiring a
bailout within the next two years anyway
no no no you guys don't get it only the
people we directly and acutely effected
get any money so I do think it's
important to note that one is crony
capitalism and one is an appropriate
purview of government if they see this
as an action yeah and we shouldn't treat
Boeing the same way we treat the nail
salon down the street yeah it's very
different exactly too-big-to-fail sorry
don't believe it I believe that
Southwest these other airlines we
haven't required bailouts will step up
an American Airlines should cease to
exist big fan of Airlines are you a big
fan of Airlines big fan of big banks big
fan of health insurance industries these
are the industry's big fan of big energy
these are the industries and companies
that have been bailed out time after
time after time and guess what there
haven't been nearly as many new
competitors you can't compete with a
never-ending supply of federal funds we
need to delineate between that and the
people who've been directly affected
because the government effectively shut
down their business here's something
else no one wants to talk about this but
since it's morning and I don't have to
go by showing up and just we don't pay
back china's debt until they fix this
yeah you know what I would say 1.2
trillion no sorry that's saying we're
never gonna pay it but you know what you
should cut you should give us a discount
you should give the whole world a
discount by the way for lying about this
for being dishonest for not telling
people what was actually happening and
NATO let's say you know what NATO we're
paying 3.6 percent the international
agreement is 2 percent the average I
believe is somewhere between 1 to 1.3
percent what most nations pay we pay 3.6
we say guess what we're just gonna pay
the average anyone else pays until they
step up yeah right there you're talking
about anywhere from 500 billion to 1.5
trillion dollars hmm let's start
rearranging this here let's stop footing
the bill
for the rest of the world just like the
rest of the world is looking to us for
some kind of a cure right now and who do
we look to not the government but
private industry and the rest of the
world benefits from our evidence the
same thing you know what you don't get
the subsidized drugs this is true I
sometimes you can order name-brand drugs
from Canada and they're cheaper than the
United States why because all the costs
are burdened here in the United States
it cost more here it's subsidized abroad
and so they don't have to pay as much
guess what if you want to use
american-made or American manufactured
drugs invented here in the United States
from American pharmaceutical companies
you pay a premium our people pay less
off the bat you pay more yeah this is
this is the America first that I can be
on board with not tariffs not trying to
shut down global free enterprise or
trade on a fair level which isn't
happening with China most of the time
but this idea that we shouldn't be
footing the bill for everyone else right
now I don't know is it me is it me no
but I see it a second how about we cut
some funding in NATO
how about we tell China to go [ __ ] on
wire brush and rotate until they decide
to figure their crap out we're not
they're not gonna be holding our debt
and let's make people pay for the drugs
that we create and invent same thing
right now coronavirus this is what
happens people say oh it's cruel really
why isn't it cruel for you to suckle -
at our teat for decades these people
brag about socialized healthcare just
like they brag about having a smaller
military guys here it works here why did
it work there sure well you have a
smaller military budget campaign why
because we foot the bill yeah and then
they look to us for health care no it no
we shouldn't subsidize the world
we shouldn't fund the world for health
care why should you all benefit from our
private health care industry and it said
well why you simultaneously demonize it
between every single election I do think
that there's an incredible amount of
people who realized the dichotomy
between saying hey Canada you want to
benefit from being our neighbor from all
of the military problems we have the
collateral benefit the candidate gets
from being next to America is people
don't can't even imagine economically
militarily right all the different
things that benefit Canada and sure okay
it's fine you guys want to criticize
this hey we're definitely the land of
dissent right where we have a free media
right everything is a double cross right
they don't have it as much they're gonna
they're gonna shut you down on on aid
speech but the whole point of the matter
is just there's a simple list now if you
want the Bennett you want the benefits
you're gonna have to pay for it and when
I say pay for it I don't necessarily
mean money per se right
be support it could be being on board
with certain policies that we have it
could be on board with punishing come
other countries that shouldn't be right
the number of times where Canada has
diverged when we've said hey we don't
like those civil rights abuses in this
country we're gonna put sanctions on
them and the rest of the world goes oh I
can't believe I can't believe you would
punish those socialists for murdering
dissidents and LGBTs and and all I can't
believe you would continue to do that
America just get on board just say hey
guys if you want the benefits yeah you
got to take the rest because you know it
is a great example we have to have to
get to a guest here but a great example
is the sort of if you look at the chasm
between people being offended by Chinese
virus versus the people of China so the
American media is like you can't say
that because there's going to be
violence committed against Chinese
Americans which of course none of us
want to see but then you look at people
who are trying to circumvent the Chinese
government the censorship and they're
going tell the world tell the world that
it's the Chinese virus because they
harmed us these people are upset with
government keep in mind that guy who
said Donald Trump don't just China China
is a [ __ ] that guy was he was a North
American they feel about the government
empathizing with the Chinese people
requires ridiculing the Chinese
government because they are it is it is
amazing that this has been allowed to go
unchecked and you have all these
economist gonna say well China is the
next great superpower of the world you
know what
only if good people don't stop them and
do something because this is there has
to be somewhere where it stops and
people are no longer abused by one of
the most oppressive regimes that we can
think of in modern mankind let's not act
as though American workers in a Ford
plant are on the same playing field as
the kids working at an Apple Factory
it's not fair it's not right we need to
do something as Americans do we have on
the line I believe we have right now our
guest for the show Mahmood Alma mood and
he is the director of public relations
at Isis Mahmood are you there sir I am
here to Steven thank you for having me
thank you I'm glad to see you sir you
look bright eyed and bushy tailed what
from where are you calling right there
I'm seeing some boxes behind you
yeah I'm odd we're doing quarantine you
know here in Anbar province we've been
deemed by Anbar province to be
non-essential okay so here I am well I
looks more like somewhere where you
would be lined up for a police photo
what are those
in the white wall it looks like the
usual suspects well you know there are
blurred lines for sure let me ask you
how are you how are you adapting right
now with Isis to the new social law
distancing guidelines you know
quarantine bears a very close
resemblance to my actual life okay so
how so many ways we've been in
quarantine since 2003 or so so you know
being in this subterranean bunker is a
kind of life as usual okay all right
what do you have any do you have any big
plans for the quarantine then or Jimmy
plans when you're done with it yeah you
know trying to do a little bit of spring
cleaning for sure I've been into this
Tiger King have you seen Tiger King I
have I have been watching Tiger King
that is not emblematic of all of the
United States by the way okay we are all
we are all Joe exotic yeah pretty much
everyone here is like yeah you know so
Carroll killed her do you think Carroll
killed her husband and fed her to the
Tigers we're trying to recruit Carroll
bats so I'll just leave it there
she's so effective she's so effective
yeah yeah okay what do you guys do yo
Casey what do you do as far as social I
think you froze there for a second a
social distancing you're also washing
hands it's a little bit different there
in your culture because you eat from the
communal bowl and you know we had a
toilet paper shortage but you guys don't
necessarily use toilet paper so how does
it affect people like you and respect
even if that's what you're getting at
yeah it's absolutely it's absolutely
through and so so we will we will we
will see how it how it's going do you
have enough toilet paper over there no
we don't that's a problem and I live
with a dog I know you guys aren't big
fans of that and her she loves toilet
paper that's her thing so it's it's the
worst living being you could possibly
have in the house with
during this quarantine I'll take you
that's not that's not good okay what's
this this is I see what you're doing
there you're trying to well look ii can
do that i can drink from my mug and lick
how is advertising egypt
what is he is he advertising for a
tourist spot for egypt egypt oh it's
lovely this time of year have we yeah
well we're also we also we're planning
on going to medina but that had to be
canceled very recently because you know
can't be too safe you know the large
groups right now right it's it's a it's
a it's very tough well though i think
more people are actually trampled going
to Medina and Mecca on an annual basis
than the coronavirus so you know you
take some like so many things in life
you know it's it's it's a balance of
risks yes it is a balance of risk and I
appreciate you letting us know that hey
we do have to get going here but my mood
what would be what's your hope or what
advice do you have to Americans as the
the public relations director for Isis
yeah you know well I I think that I
think that the the the the end is near
as I often say hopefully hopefully
hopefully it's something where we can
find a lot of common ground right and
and then we can get back to where you're
scared of me okay
Mahmood Alma mood stay safe use your
hose on your left hand don't eat from
the communal bowl we will see you next
time thank you sir no I don't want him
to trace our call
Mahmood l Mahmood showing the softer
side of Isis what a guy he's just he's a
lover were you about to say something
there I quarter black carrot you look
like at one point you were leaning in no
no I was just listening oh you ready
hey look CNN look another guy talking
from his from his closet
this is remarkable to me I will say this
these these production companies you
look at CNN you look at these late night
hosts they're so used to having I think
Leno had 147 employees I know it's over
a hundred for every late-night show it's
well over 100 for most these shows at
CNN not to mention writers producers
segments producers and what happens is
they have all this money and it
goes away because of a self quarantine
and so they just decide well just turn
on your iPhone like you can there's a
middle there's a minute round look at
what we're doing here yeah they're not
anything this is what happens this is
the great equalizer when there's some
kind of a pandemic going on we can
create better more polished content and
then all of CNN think about that for a
second this is more pop the shoe know
what when people think of Lionel's
credit you don't think polish as a
matter of fact what we told you guys
when we said mug Club quarantine month
everything's going to be free in front
of the paywall plus more content than
ever because we want to interact with
you what we told you was listen there's
gonna be less polish I didn't anticipate
this I didn't anticipate someone
broadcasting from George Michael's
port-a-potty in Los Angeles at a public
park
I like how you know what do they say you
don't have to run the fastest you just
have to run faster than the last guy
right and that's Alaska CMS race to the
middle and this is also why they're
putting pressure on on YouTube and all
these sort of new media companies right
because what happened is they had this
sort of not not a monopoly but a few
major news networks right they were on
cable that's what people had and they
had this kind of classic corporate
budget cost structure and now they can't
afford it and well it's a race to the
middle they're trying to downgrade
they're trying to cut down costs we're
building up right so they're coming down
from 140 employees to maybe I don't know
like 90 and we're going from 8 12 15
hopefully one day maybe 20 employees you
know join mug Club $30 off this month
its quarantine we're not making anything
off of YouTube so we're intersecting
there at the middle so what happens NBC
Vox universal they try to step in and
get YouTube to shut down competitors do
you have a bee seed is it ABC Disney ABC
vision is they step in and they say you
know what we're gonna try and flag and
copyright and shut down people who
criticize our content then they start
running more advertising dollars on
YouTube so that they can manipulate what
gets seen more what's considered
advertiser friendly and it still doesn't
work people are not tuning in so there
is a silver lining here right now that I
think we've learned the media is not the
same while we've known this for a while
but it's on showcase right now 24 hours
right yeah they're not the people that
we thought they were they don't care
about you and
and most of all and most offensively of
all they're incredibly lazy and right
now they're running an ad for st. Jude
that's nice but I've been looking at see
it's been nothing but like gold you
would think that people who watch CNN
spend their days crapping themselves
buying precious metals all day they were
nodding up on their camper do them
what's the median age down to now 93 hey
don't knock it
come on don't have long 93 year olds to
our water airport by the way what are
CNN's ratings right now because no one's
at the airport are they County no one's
no one's in the dentist's office lobby
we're just playing non-stop the greatest
compliment Anderson Cooper's receive is
actually aged pretty well you turn on
the gas that's about that's what they
have on Rotten Tomatoes yeah it's like
every office you go in just has it
playing on background you're like so
it's so it's so low quality it can be
the yani of the elevator
it's your music yeah where the lobbies
usually noise let me tell you a Yanni
song ooh I got them all what what give
me a guy actually so you know I played
violin in a lot of weddings yeah I know
it's tough and I don't know you get at
weddings yeah we played it like you're a
very well paid lawyer 50 weddings I mean
but I've been doing it since I was a kid
like my sister and I would you know
every other weekend would play at
weddings and you know make some money
cream on stuff
yeah pre bar and I've had a couple
themed weddings that I've had to play in
and one of them was like all Yanni songs
one was and yeah one was gonna see our
hero songs what would that even mean
guitar hero like yeah I did play songs
from guitar hero one cuz that was out of
this couple met they met playing guitar
hero I don't like that well I don't like
that story I don't like it I don't like
it when people when people they get cute
with their wedding like we link our so
they dress up like Chewbacca and r2 or
like we're we're are indie so they wear
converse all-stars like this is the one
opportunity where you have to be yeah
follow the tradition class it up yeah
Dave it was not classy yeah meeting
meeting a guitar hero it's know Pride
and Prejudice sorry for the ages I mean
no one was like oh amazing I look back
fondly Franz Ferdinand
not great not great I just you know
what's crazy
what when was the last time we did $30
off so last time I did $30 off gosh I
don't know of course like students
veterans get it but sure now everyone
gets $30 off it was of oxide apocalypse
he was reminded cuz when you were
talking about where you know all the
different folks who are having to deal
with the media and whether they can
trust these things and how this platform
goes around yeah only way it happens is
Mudd Club
yeah in this room that was all the only
way we had it back there and thank you
so so much everyone is joining again
we're doing this because this is how we
can give back we have decided to take an
acceptable risk and everyone here is
quarantined just at the office and just
at home washing your hands hand
sanitizer everywhere though I want to be
honest I'm not really it none of us here
at significant risk so we're not it's
not exactly kamikaze anchor Harbor like
going out nurse no I mean he might but
the point is like it's not that big a
deal and we figured we could serve you
more and a lot of people out there we
know that what we noticed more people
are watching in the morning
yeah the evening shows in the morning
because you get up you aren't
necessarily going to work and people are
listening to the show at home and so we
said okay three times a week let's do
this where we can interact with folks
and I don't know if we have the chat at
the blaze by the way for people who are
who are looking to use it go to blaze
comm slash TVs that are blaze blaze
tv.com
you can chat there the only issue we
tried to get this up and running
immediately you can't put in your user
name yet so in your comment just put
your name and colon and that should be
fixed here within the next two weeks
because we wanted to make sure we have
the chat right there we don't reduce
uper chat on YouTube because not only do
they not pay us but then they can spy on
us right now
so we want you in that doing that
talking to people in some interesting
question off the ticket audience you
want some inside baseball before the
last story of the day of speaking of
media did I ever tell you the story
about when I went into a meeting at
MSNBC no no so okay can i I can talk
about this now right I can't either
okay news for four and a half four and a
half years okay and what happened was
initially my contract was like six
months yeah for a couple every six
months every six months every six months
and I found out they would do this a lot
of the younger contributors I was by
young I mean I was 20 maybe I was 21 and
the only other guy who was my age was
Peter Doocy Steve Doocy son who
basically showed up drunk all the time
to do that so uh they'd be like hey
Steve Doocy
Pete do see Steve Doocy son what's
what's gonna be going out and there on
the street you send your own guy that's
a horrible report so I was very young
outside of him my point is you know I
don't really think he counts and then
every six months we'd have to sit down
for renewal and sometimes it would lapse
for like two weeks so at one period had
elapsed for two weeks and I was tulip
hearing and I met with some executives
at MSNBC
and I didn't really know I was meeting
with them I thought I was meeting with
someone who was doing things so I hope
I'm fine here it's not a violation
because the contract had lapsed I had no
interest in going to MSNBC but Alex
Wagner was there Alex Wagner citizens I
have never used your name so now you
have the inside scoop she's there she
does like the the world's greatest
circus it's a show on Showtime now or
something okay very liberal she was a
hosted MSM you see so I go in some
executives are there and they were
talking about Rick Perry because this
was back in the the primary you know was
still Rick Perry
yeah and Mitt Romney and they said we
heard that Rick Perry is is gay do you
think he's gay I said I don't I have no
what are you what are you talking about
I don't know and they were going to size
very high possibility and so just got
quiet nice and well Hillary Clinton's a
dyke they said well I said well I have a
source that says that so I'm gonna say
that yeah they said well what's your
source I said what's your source that
was very childish this will our Shore
ours is anonymous don't mines anonymous
man she was talking about Alex Wagner
was there and she was talking about
she's like yeah you know I studied at
the Sorbonne and speaks French and she
says so I speak French and some
international story and so I said oh is
a [ __ ] about fall well my my super
compound but badly I'll say yes she
responded for Walter out she didn't
maybe she does now she didn't speak a
word of French she they had no interest
in me working at MSNBC but it was just
remarkable to be on the show and she was
like she was like pronouncing French
words the way someone who wasn't French
but wanted a sound friend would
pronounce them a little bit of inside
baseball every now and then because
hopefully it's not a legal violation of
contract did I enjoy my time at Fox News
I didn't so much enjoy that delivery
letters hey let's show it Sanjay Gupta
and John King they all hate Trump that's
an interesting perspective attention to
not saying but they're gonna be fine
they haven't had many cases yet they're
gonna be fiery as was he turning the big
fires without social distance is a
fundamental just a fundamental
difference John between what we were
hearing just last week this idea that
maybe those places could start to be
overs the disease narratives pay more
attention to them first of all John just
practically speaking it's really about
the the number of people per capita that
oh good okay people whenever you look at
these maps look at think about this per
capita New York obviously much more
densely populated some of these other
areas but number two we haven't been
doing testing there yet we really don't
know how significant the problem is
don't use like the numbers should matter
per capita like oh that's some good news
because per capita we're doing far
better than these other countries as far
as death rate but we really don't have
enough testing but hold on a second our
overall infection rate is higher than
anywhere else because we have an obscene
amount of testing right now we're
testing a lot of people yeah and we're
also not lying about our testing let's
be really clear about that I do realize
I thought last night that I was going
through some stuff kind of getting ready
for this and well you know just doing
the kind of browse looking on a very
social media but also reading news sites
and not a single article talks about the
lack of testing as it relates to other
countries every single one of them is
criticizing the United States saying
there's not enough testing here 300 plus
million people you should have more
tests etc here it's a it's a failure the
government of Trump you know it cetera
cetera but not a single one of them is
posting about other countries that have
even worse systems like like they don't
have any tests at all but there were
actually a few people on social media
who I thought they just they're just
people I've either known from high
school or other places who just said
look I don't know what's going on but I
can tell you this I I don't believe that
there are these other countries that
don't that have zero numbers right now
that are being reported by the media is
having zero or like single-digit
releases of infection not even death and
yet we're saying we there's no number of
testing that's happening there so you're
telling me those are the numbers we
should believe right is why the only
number you can really trust right is
and you still can't trust the most
accurate number we have is a total
number of deaths not even the mortality
rate as a percentage of the disease
because we don't know how many people
have it and now they're determining that
more people have it who are asymptomatic
which again you hear that you go oh okay
so more but you'll have it then we
realize they're asymptomatic or it's
very mildly go that means they can
transmit it on a second
let's look at the bright side that means
that the death rate is much lower you
guys were saying 6% 5% 3% it's well
under 1% particularly for people who are
under the age of 80 years old well yeah
and those those are the only things we
have to compare it to we I can only
compare it to how other countries are
handling this exact thing right like we
can look back and see other pandemics
and how other presidents may have
handled those but we the only other
people who are handling this one are the
other countries around us yeah that it
depends on what you compare it and it's
remarkable to me when they compare us to
South Korea so clones like South Korea
is a country first off they didn't trust
the the Intel from China they got on it
really quickly they actually did farm it
out to private testing and by the way
some of these tests that were created by
threat private companies were offered to
the CDC FDA but they weren't approved
only the FDA only the CDC's kits were
approved by the FDA the ones that go in
to your brain Korona
or in it it's just a problem and so
South Korea had privatized testing and
the government basically docks their
citizens if you are willing to do that
this is something we need to take into
account should your data be given over
to the government and should they then
have the right to post it publicly so
people know where to avoid Corona hot
spots let's be really clear this does
matter it doesn't mean that you don't
care about lives if you care about the
lives of every American thereafter who
basically dissolves all of their rights
to a government because imagine if this
imagine if this were to happen under a
government was like a 20% death rate
which is what they always predicted when
they were putting like a global pandemic
in the contagion they were talking 20 30
40 % death rate right and you're talking
about like a third of the world being
infected right so imagine if we were in
an actual pandemic how quickly your
rights would go away and not just
because of the government violently
season them Donald Trump hasn't been
doing this because of the people
demanding it in the media demanding it
if you don't demand that there is a
federal lockdown that puts all
businesses out of work as we know them
right now you for some
reason don't care about the people who
are being lost to Corona which by the
way if you calculate it all it's still
less at this point then flu deaths yeah
we need to take all of these things into
account by the way we don't have time
for the commercials because we run a
little bit late so black rifle coffee
they are still in business right now
it's delicious but now it's cold because
we've been sitting here for an hour and
10 yeah but the black rifle delicious
this is my favorite blend it's there a
vintage roast black rifle coffee calm
slash Trotter entering the promo code
Crowder and you will get 20% off your
first order we really appreciate you
know who needs all of that it's the
people who were stealing coffee from
their office and they can't get it
anymore just let black rifles in history
to your house absolutely right easy
you could also trade trade it if the
crap really goes down our commodity that
can be trade traded right Everclear and
black rifle coffee you're saying guns so
you can take other people's black rifle
coffee and Everclear
yeah that's really what's most important
again the hash tag is we're gonna have
to get going here tonight we do have a
show which is we have life advice as
well as a meat segment it's gonna be
going up tonight tomorrow we have raised
your fists in the show just like a
Thursday show and the promo code is
quarantine you get $30 off all of us of
course is going to be provided to you in
front of the paywall for for the month
of April it's my club quarantine month
and check out Crowder bit subscribe
there because there might be some
exclusive content we really do
appreciate it and of course mug club
people who've already joined the ones
who make this possible let's get to the
last story right now because nothing's
been changing in the news they've been
complaining about president Trump's
really bad job right this is what
they're trying to run with so I think we
have a clip right now about Pelosi
putting Donald Trump on blast if you
look at the headlines over there at the
Huffington Post Ursula no man in the
world is really I mean he has to deal
with John King doing a Skype hit with
female Skeletor he's quivering in his
boots clearing in his to Kovas aren't a
sponsor yet they will be soon
let's roll clip three are you saying
that that his downplaying
ultimately cost American lives yes I am
I'm saying that because what when he
made the other day when he was signing
the bill he said just think twenty days
ago
everything was great no everything
wasn't great we had nearly
hundred cases and 17 deaths already and
in that 20 days because we weren't
prepared we now have two thousand deaths
in 100,000 cases this matters because
the content know everything wasn't okay
we had 500 cases and 17 deaths I don't
know the source in front Li but I'm
pretty sure that's fewer deaths than
people from toasters in that period of
time so our peoples jumped on toast the
more we love choked on toast that's why
they're gonna sponsor is the threat
darkening machine of bread darkening box
yeah bread jogging box te OAS t.com 20%
off entering the promo code toast the
reason why most people looked at that
said okay a couple hundred infected 17
deaths that's really not serious because
statistically it's really not at that
point and that's why it was the left it
was people like you Pelosi and people in
New York who were saying that it wasn't
a big deal and actually discouraged
people from actively leaving because
they thought there was a threat posed if
you don't believe me here's a clip
these clip for ya the important thing
for New Yorkers to know is that in the
city currently their risk is low and our
city preparedness is high and so we know
that this virus can be transmitted from
one individual to another but that it's
typically people who live together that
there's no risk at this point in time
we're always learning more about having
it be transmitted in casual contact
yeah the gray hair tulsi Ward Bennett's
I just feel like that information was
wrong no I can hear there you go
this also matters because the World
Health Organization downplayed it taking
advice from China early on saying that
there was no evidence I think we have
these as overlays of human contact and
they recommended against travel
restriction yes in January
here's another fast fact during that
period Donald Trump finished creating a
Chinese virus task force January 19th
less than a week after the World Health
Organization said there was no evidence
of human to human transmission then he
banned Trump a trump band traveled to
China this is important to note which
biden accused him of being xenophobic
for
that's clip 5 this is no time for Donald
Trump's record of hysteria xenophobia
hysterical xenophobia hmm this is no
time for games
I don't really I don't know what
xenophobia means um I know from what I
understand is the fear of everything
fear of anything that DIF for not
familiar yes that's and I think that
everybody has a certain level of
xenophobia than if you're talking about
being introduced to something new I know
other words people are cautious no
matter what it is if you're walking on
new ground in the for IO is look for
bear traps because Wolverine some guns
get caught in them and then they chew
off their own leg and they chase down
the person who laid the bear trap
because they tracked down the scent and
I wrote a short story about it in grade
school I failed miserably mainly because
I just ripped off Jurassic Park and
replaced the velociraptors with the
Wolverine the point is check for bear
traps it's a concern please and don't
plagiarize Steven Spielberg if you're in
school mmm they catch on to that sort of
ladies and gentlemen this whole
coronavirus is just a cover-up for the
bear trace cover-up for bear big bear
trap you can get them at Menards and I
think I confuse it with Gander Mountain
Gander Mountain is the outdoor one the
point is if you need a bear trap there's
a way to find it on the dark web or you
can whopper to Amy's hardware you can
also find we don't really need the dark
web or a VPN but Ace Hardware so yeah
there are multiple ways to skin a cat
this is remarkable to me Donald Trump
cut down travel to China right put a ban
in place which they accused him of being
racist doing that this was keep in mind
at a time on the World Health
Organization who by the way when they
had the conversations excluded Taiwan
which to me is very telling did you see
that video of the World Health
Organization the representative there he
was being interviewed on skype and he
just acted like he didn't hear the
question regarding Taiwan he says I
don't know we can bring it up or we can
bring it up tonight he said I don't I
didn't hear you the cut out she said
well let me ask you again
he said no let's move on to the next
question Wow so this idea that the World
Health Organization by the way that
these these sort of international
governmental bodies have no bias is
completely untrue because they were
saying there was no risk at this
Point Donald Trump said you know what I
think there's some risk we're gonna have
a task force we're gonna ban travel to
China so no no there's no risk and then
Joe Biden said hey that's racist and now
they're blaming him for not having done
enough and that is probably why our last
fast fact here Donald Trump is gaining
and actually eclipsing Joe Biden due to
the crisis more people approve of
president Trump's handling of the crisis
than ever before and Joe Biden is not
doing so well and I don't mean that he's
not just doing well in the polls
I mean he's not doing well in that
Corona should be the least of his
worries he should be concerned about
that about that cranial microbe that was
it cat pee or cat poop in Brazil that
makes people really aggressive the
soccer players whatever is happening
there there's something short-circuiting
and Biden's brain hey it's really hard
for the guy all he has is challenging
people to push-ups but he has to stay so
far away from them right now right no
one to challenge and he doesn't and he
can't do push-ups in the ground because
then he has a problem with the contact
yeah it's terrible it's also can't do
push-ups because he's incredibly weak
it's hard out there for a while he would
actually probably fare more poorly than
women at PT in the Marines at this point
are you looking over there do we have
are we bring anything we have that clip
of this person avoiding the question
yeah let's bring up this clip this is
that representative of the World Health
Organization again and not to be a sore
spot but you and I and we've talked
about Taiwan Taiwan can have been left
out in the cold here and it's relevant
here's the World Health Organization I
don't member his name representative
playing it off like he didn't hear the
question
Oh consider Taiwan's membership
hello I couldn't hear your question okay
yeah let me let me repeat the question
right like this because I'm I'm actually
curious I'm talking about Taiwan as well
on Taiwan's case what and he closes it
what Wow when you can keep in mind I
don't think this is I don't think this
is a conspiracy or theory at this point
where you say China has not been the
Chinese government they've not been
honest or forthright about what's been
happening with the coronavirus and the
World Health Organization has not
treated all nations equally they've been
carrying the water of the Chinese
government not the Chinese people I
don't know why the Taiwanese couldn't
have a membership does that make you
might know more about that doesn't seem
like a Taiwan II should at least be
involved well then the big deal the
nutshell is that China doesn't recognize
Taiwan as a separate nation it
recognizes it only as a rogue state that
is part of China so any national or
international organization that
recognizes Taiwan instantly goes on the
China [ __ ] list right and they just say
look if you recognize Taiwan as its own
country you're dead to us and so the
w-h-o is an international organization
that receives support from another
number of countries and of the big five
China is one of them and so when China
says hey we're gonna stop cooperating
with you or funding you or whatever it
may be who knows what these
conversations are like but we do know
what they could be like because it's the
same public conversation that China has
all the time if you're recognized Taiwan
you're dead to us so we know what's
happening here in that reporter had an
opportunity to ask so what's really get
the opportunity right and we set aside
our political differences China Taiwan
in this pandemic are we going to care
about Taiwan and somebody was going
through a tunnel with their skype right
yeah relevant because of the way the
government would be the government would
be handling it right Taiwan they would
be operating they would be operating
autonomously from China certainly how
they're dealing with this yes in their
country well they would be operating
autonomously they would be getting
support from a lot of their own
supporters which includes the United
States right they have a different
government but if you think about the
places that are highly at risk we're all
concerned about Korea because it's so
connected there to China just across in
and on another peninsula Taiwan and
China the number of flights between
those two countries I don't know what
they are but the amount
travelled right or indirectly in that
hemisphere that includes Taiwan is
extraordinary so when you think about a
place that's going to need support and
certainly wants to know does it have the
support of the World Health Organization
and they can't even get an answer yeah
it's a big concern and keep in mind the
World Health Organization this is the
organization that went with this these
studies right these projections if you
look at their Twitter you look at their
social media that 2.5 million Americans
would die the idea that the Chinese
government did great work and everything
that they could to try and contain this
virus I don't know if they retweeted it
but certainly the Chinese government did
their foreign minister repeatedly that
this was actually a virus created by the
American soldiers by the way and people
were cut responding when Donald Trump
responded in kind calling it the Chinese
virus why does it matter because they do
not get to rewrite history again aiming
it at the Chinese government the World
Health Organization if you look at the
timeline all of the information that has
been fed to the international community
from China World Health has echoed it
almost exactly to a tee and then when
questioned about Taiwan again he was an
ally the United States supports them we
recognize them I believe
we certainly understand that they are
that do we officially recognize them as
a country they say it's some capacities
yes it's a complicated issue but they
operate autonomously in a lot of ways in
a way that we would actually be required
to provide them with some kind of aid
and we do they cannot even answer the
question that should tell you how
terrified they are and how beholden not
to the people of China but to the
government of China that they actually
are and keep in mind this is the same
organization that ranked the United
States I believe 36th an international
healthcare right next to Slovenia and
Colombia so do they have a vested
interest in playing down success of the
United States and do they have a vested
interest in trying to parrot the
messages coming from the Chinese
government they certainly have done that
they've done that thus far consistently
and it's something that we need to be
concerned with especially if we are
talking about shutting down the American
economy and by proxy the global economy
as the result of this information which
is by and large being provided to us by
the world healthcare organization
following the money following the
relationships it does matter and if we
if we leave you with nothing else right
now we will see you tonight at 9:00 p.m.
Eastern it is this that I understand
people care on all different size
people care they don't want their
grandparents to die and neither do I
they don't want people who are at risk
to die neither do I and people on the
other side also care when they say I
don't want every friend I know to be
unemployed or small business that I know
to go under sure the big boys may
survive because of the never-ending
supply of corporate bailouts but guess
what a lot of small businesses will
shudder their doors forevermore there is
a balance to be had here and I think the
numbers do matter
especially the source of those numbers
we're talking with the world health care
organization the numbers matter for us
to balance the risk/reward ratio it
doesn't mean that you don't care about
any lives lost if you want to prevent
damage going forward as effectively as
possible both health-wise and
economically this has been a good
morning mug club we really appreciate
you being with us we'll see you again
every night through Thursday 9:00 p.m.
Eastern and we'll be back here Wednesday
morning good morning mug club at 10:00
p.m. 10:00 a.m. each camp
[Music]
if he's rather nice then you have it oh
no really I think you ought to give him
a chance he seems kind of helplessness
is the last thing I am looking for
[Music]
even Sammy
[Music]
even Sammy
please if we're going to spend the rest
of our lives together you must learn not
to interrupt mr. panner
[Music]
you realize what you've said I should do
it's pound into my brain often enough
asleep and awake in the drowsy hands as
a moment of every lonely dawn oh come on
what's your answer you take my breath
away no it's just the sudden realization
you see of the vector if I love you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]